you
[Music]
my talk today is called swimming in the
data River or when streaming analytics
isn't so the what I'm going to talk
about in this talk is sort of a
whirlwind tour of what's going on in the
streaming analytics space and a little
pet peeve of mine that we'll get into
annabet but first who am i I'm generally
no I'm a committer and PMC member on
Apache druid which is a project
incubating Apache right now a real-time
analytical database I'm a co-founder at
imply which is a company built around
druid and I spent the last 10 years or
so working on scalable systems a lot of
them open source we want to talk about
today so first I want to talk about what
I mean by swinging the data River so
this sort of evolution from the old
school of data warehouses to the new
world of streaming and how we got here
and also where we're going talk a little
bit about streaming analytics talk about
druid of course because that's what I
work on and I'm very excited about it
and how that fits into the whole world
and then also drew it as open source you
can probably tell from the fact that
it's got an Apache in front of the name
so do try this at home how you can join
the Apache droid community first off
rolling down the river let's talk about
let's talk about warehouses rivers all
that good stuff so this is a good slide
this is this light everybody puts up and
then says you know let's talk about how
we're better than this so it's it's
everyone likes to dump on data
warehouses I'm not super creative so I'm
gonna do the same thing
data warehouse is their thing they were
really the first way that people did
meaningful business analytics on data
super popular starting from the
beginning of the database world in the
70s and really the unquestioned kings of
analytics until the dawn of the big data
era in the early 2000s they've got a few
well-known issues one issue is you have
to do ETL process before you get data
into the into the warehouse near the end
of the data warehouse era a lot of the
data warehouse vendors we're talking
about doing alt instead of ETL so
loading first and then transforming
rather than transforming and then load
the ETL of course stands for extract
data from where it is transform it into
useful form and load it into a database
but even with ELT you still have to get
it into this world
a channel format before it can be loaded
into a data warehouse so there's still
work to do even to do a pure load and
then transform later so that's a
downside it means a lot of people were
just not able to get data into these
things at all and we're just dropping it
on the ground
another one of the well-known issues is
that all these apps on the side does
this work yeah all these apps on the
side are very thin querying apps that do
all their computation inside the data
warehouse so they can only do what the
warehouse lets them do they can run
sequel they can some of them let you run
store procedures but they are
fundamentally sort of these platforms
that embed both story and computing in
the same system and so they're they're a
bit rigid so where does that go that
that famously is starting it replaced by
data lakes about you know maybe 10 15
years ago data lakes are interesting so
these are you know this is a what really
came about in the dawn of the big data
era and they're interesting because if
you think about it one of the cool
things that they do is they push ETL
later you can put raw data into a data
Lake you can transform it later there's
no real reason this had to be concurrent
with the dawn of the Big Data era
nothing about this is a big data thing
it's sort of just for I guess it's an
accident of history we got introduced to
Big Data and got introduced to this
concept of just loading raw data
unstructured data semi structured data
and transforming it later around the
same time the same set of tools
empowered both ok I think I'm the sort
of separate things and then the apps
that want to go on top of this are much
bigger apps so you have you know as the
modern data warehouse is actually you
can think of it as a sequel app for data
Lake that's something like hive or
presto is I would think of it as more of
an application than a traditional data
warehouse although you can do a lot of
the same use cases it's it's an app for
data Lake rather than than a data
warehouse you can do machine learning
and on top of these things you can load
data in other kinds of apps time series
databases so so having this explosion of
possibility out of apps is one nice
thing we got in the Big Data world not
just ability to scale but also the
ability to have be much more creative
with the kinds of applications that we
that we use to operate on our data one
of the things that I believe and one of
the things we believe in the India patch
is that this architecture while it's
really exploded in popularity over the
last 10-15 years is not gonna last as
long as data warehouses did they'd
warehouses rained for 40 years and then
they'll be replaced by data rivers so
streaming architectures streaming
architectures are you get all the same
benefits as these sort of data Lake big
data architectures you get to have
really big creative apps you get to load
unstructured semi-structured data and
then figure out to do it later you get
all the same benefits but everything's
happening in streams in real time
instead of batch delivery so that fact
means you know you get all the benefits
Plus this one additional huge benefit of
everything happening in real time and
being able to react data as it happens
to me means that this architecture is
the one that's going to last the next
4050 years you can even see that one of
the things that architecture does the
data lakes not going to go away forever
there's still reasons you might want to
do to sort of have this big area of
storage to do batch computation in
generic way but it becomes sort of
subservient you sort of have a tributary
from your data River into a data Lake
that's at that bottom right application
it's still going into s3 or HDFS or
whatever but that's not the primary way
you think about interacting with data so
with that being said let's say we want
to go to a streaming architecture how do
we do it it's a it's a really crazy
brave new world all the applications
have changed we just went through a
world where all the applications change
when we move to big data we know we
threw away all of our data warehouses we
threw away our Postgres and now we have
hive and presto and now we're talking
about going to streaming architectures
we have to throw it all out and start
over again it gets confusing and weird
confluent a company based on Kafka
they're like you know sort of like Kafka
sort of like for Kafka would imply is
for Droid has this cool picture they put
on a lot of their talks in blog posts
that is a really neat looking streaming
architecture that goes around a
streaming platform very kind of them to
write the word streaming platform
they're not Kafka they're being very
generous and but it still doesn't tell
you what you wanna do it's a cool
picture it's a cool picture that looks
really neat and tidy but there's a lot
of questions questions like
how does how does data move between
these systems what are these these
little gray lines are everywhere what
are those gray lines you have a little
box that says monitoring what does that
mean is that alerting is it
charting is it observability is it APM
you have a box called security that
seems weird is that an application is
that a set of requirements is it just
there because we want to have the word
security here somewhere what is what
does that mean you have search and no
sequel on the side but what are you
doing with them you have apps on the top
our search of no sequel apps do they
need apps like I don't know what's
what's going on here so there's a lot of
questions and what I'm thinking is let's
start simple and let's talk about just
some basic things we can do with
streaming data so here's a much simpler
picture there's two boxes and there's
one arrow I have a app and I have a
stream hub and the stream hub is like
Kafka Kinesis Google pub/sub whatever I
have an app using the library for that
stream hub they all have their own
libraries I'm pushing it into it ok
that's cool now I have data in there
maybe I'm pushing data about you know
what people are clicking on my site you
know whatever it doesn't matter I have
some data in my stream pub now there's
other ways I can get data in there I can
do what's called change data capture
where the app uses a transactional
database to do its thing so you know I
have a shopping cart and I when I put
something my shopping cart updates a
record in my sequel and then I have to
some change data capture running from my
sequel into my stream hub so every
insert and update and delete in my
sequel triggers a message of hearing my
stream hub so I can I can do this it's
no way of getting data in I can also get
data out so what do i do once I have
data in my stream up I can get it out I
can put it back into a data Lake so I
can use my stream hub as a way to get
data into a data lake that's a very
basic use of a stream hub but for a lot
of people it's actually the first thing
they do with it
I can put it into a database so I can
you know I can change data capture out
of a database and then put it back into
a database nothing wrong with that and
I'm using something like Kafka connect
or Kinesis firehose for this those are
data movement tools data pipeline tools
I can use it for micro services to talk
to each other so I can have you know
service number one service number two
service number one can call service
number two directly or can write a
message to my stream hub and service
number two can read it this is sort of
you know like a message passing type of
use case it's useful it's a little bit
over complicated in this diagram you
know you're thinking why is it here but
there's some reasons it decouples
service one two it means that if service
two goes down service one does not need
to be blocking for ever writing to it it
also means that if instead of service
number two there's service number two
three four five six that all need that
same output from service one rather than
service one having to write to six
different services every time something
happens it can write to the stream hub
and I can get broadcast out so there's
usefulness in this another basically you
can do but what I'm here to talk about
is analytics so let's say I want to do
analytics on these streams I don't want
to do I don't want to move data around I
don't want to just load data in I don't
want to just communicate between
micro-services I want to do some
analytics on this streaming data so I go
to the internet I type in top stream
analytics products what do I get I get
flink I get sparks streaming I get as
your stream analytics these are all
these are all stream processors so what
do these things do there's a lot of them
too there's not just what's on that list
there's also storm Solms
kafka streams there's a Kinesis one and
azure one at Google one there's a ton of
these things well the most basic thing
they can do is you load data or you you
have them you they sit on the stream
they read data from the stream they can
do some alerting they can do some API
calls so they can like do stuff they can
call an API they can send an alert based
on seeing that streaming data in this
world they're sort of they're sort of
acting like that service number two in
the micro service architecture but
instead of having to build a micro
service you can just write a stream
processing job and stream processing
jobs are much easier to build than a
micro service so they can kind of save
you some time you can also use them to
move data so just like we use something
like Kafka Connect or cases firehose to
move data somewhere I can also use a
stream processor to move data they're
capable of doing that so they're kind of
general-purpose in that sense they can
do this micro service II thing they can
do this data movement e things so
they're they're kind of general-purpose
Swiss Army knives of doing stuff with
streaming data I can also do a
continuous query and that's what gets
really interesting so a continuous query
might be a continuous stream join let's
say
doing stuff with online advertising and
I have a student impressions and a
stream of clicks I want to compute a
click-through rate I have to merge those
two join those two streams together and
so they can do things like that they can
take two streams join them into one they
can compute aggregates on streams so
they can run the continuous query and
write the results of that query back
into the stream hub and then we can send
that process data to storage or wherever
you want to send it to but what if
instead of taking that that continuous
query result instead of just dumping it
into s3 what if I want to see it in real
time if I want to see it in real time
then I want to real-time dashboard so I
have a key value store I take I run this
continuous query every time I get you
know let's say I'm doing a 5-minute
aggregation so every five minutes I have
a some counters that have updated I take
those counters I write them into H brace
Cassandra Redis whatever and then I have
a dashboard that that reads out of there
and I can see these things updating in
real time maybe I do it every minute so
I have it you know it's called real-time
updates once a minute maybe once a
minutes not good enough maybe one update
more often than that I'm only omitting
state once a minute but some of these
stream processors flink does this and a
few others do as well they let you query
data directly out of the state store of
the stream processor so instead of
having a update once a minute on my
real-time dashboard I can get updates
continuously you know down to every
single message even because I'm getting
the you know most I'm getting some
arrogance from the key value store but
I'm that I'm getting the most up-to-date
sort of partial state of the most recent
minute from the stream processor state
directly by directly querying it so it's
a cool rates on dashboard
I had this continuous query running I
can get unlimited aggregation state and
then I can do key lookups range scans in
general pre-computation in the key value
store so whenever I have some new
widgets I want to show my dashboard I
spin up a new stream processor job a new
continuous query have those results we
computed continuously write them into
that key value store load end and
visualize them in that real-time
dashboard so these are this is kind of
you know the one of the fancier things
you can do with these tools that are
called streaming analytics tools but is
this analytics I don't know maybe it's
keeping a real-time dashboard up-to-date
that's cool but
I wanted more than that so this comes to
the problem that we're trying to solve
with with the patchy druid we're trying
to make this happen at imply we make a
UI called pivot that works on druid to
slice and dice UI for flying through
your data and we want this UI to work
it's it sort of looks like a real-time
dashboard if you just have a dashboard
view up but you also we also want to
give people the ability to expand things
fly through things and and pivots fairly
a recent development you know we started
imply a few years ago and then built
that on top of Juraj or it's been around
a lot longer a George Ben an open-source
project since 2012 and since the
beginning of the jerod project people
have been using it to power these
interactive user experiences interactive
analytics and the ad hoc nature them is
really important the ability to not just
have a real-time dashboard but also be
able to drill into it so you want slice
and dice for big data streams you want
to be able to interactive exploration
you want to be able to look under the
hoods of reports and dashboards and you
want fresh data as well there's a lot of
challenges here a lot of challenges here
that that stream processors are not
really up to the task of and that you
need some sort of database for so
they're good at scale speed the good at
speed too you want sub-second response
time complexity is where things start to
fall apart
there's too much fine grained to
pre-compute so there's too much fine
green and pre compute all possible kinds
of drill downs you might want to do you
know you might have the same dashboard
you might want to filter it by country
by city by product line by browser you
might want to filter by three of them at
once
after you add enough dimensions that you
want to drill into it starts getting
really unwieldy and you start to realize
that that this technique of continuously
computing a query and writing the
results somewhere is not gonna be
effective that complexity is really
driven by the the next thing high
dimensionality so having tens or
hundreds of dimensions you might want to
slice and dice on incurrence is a big
thing so you want have building many
users to use it and you want freshness
as well so you want to be able to load
from streams you still want to maintain
this ability to see what's happening
right now so of course we made sure to
try to solve these problems
what is Druid if you look at the tag
line on the previous slide
high-performing
analytics data store Ford rent driven
data I want to unpack that a little bit
you know just like we're not a you know
we're a community project on the jury
decide on the imply side we're a small
start-up but with the best of them we
had days long sessions where we tried to
come up with the perfect tagline and I'm
so proud of it that I just wanted to say
what the things mean high performance
means low query latency high ingest
rates the two sides of the same coin
analytics means counting ranking group
by time trend that kind of thing
datastore means the cluster stores a
copy of your data and this is where it
becomes different from something that's
really focused on data in motion we're
storing a full copy of the data in Druid
and focus on being able to scan through
that data rapidly so as data gets loaded
in
we're not continuously computing the
result of a query but we're putting it
into a format that can be scanned very
rapidly as any query comes in and then
event-driven data we want to do fact
data like click stream network flows
user behavior digital marketing I
mentioned advertising earlier server
metrics that kind of thing if I go back
to a diagram like the one that we had
before so how this fits into a stream
hub world you still have this sort of
continuous query happening with stream
processors but what we're using them for
is reason them for enrichment of data so
we might still use them to join streams
together we might still use them to you
know get additional kind of detail on
the original streaming data and and make
that enriched stream but then we're
doing continuous load rather than a
continuous query into an analytical
database and add a local database is I
would say the category of things that
your it belongs to George of course not
the only one but anna little database is
a database that's designed to be able to
scan through your data really quickly
and be able to compute sort of these
very read heavy workloads speak sequel
so you have an application speaking
sequel to the database on the in the
druid world you have pivot imply pivot
that app I showed you earlier
Apache superset another Apache friend of
ours looker is a commercial UI that has
support for droid so or your app here so
like I said since the beginning of the
Jared project people have been using it
to power UIs and applications
the key features of druid are its
column-oriented so it's an animal
database column-oriented meaning it
stores your data laid out by columns any
all the data for the same column is
gonna be laid out in basically a giant
array on disk and in memory that's what
part of what gives it the fast scan
speeds I'm talking about high
concurrency due to its efficiency
scalable to hundreds of servers the
biggest cluster I know about is in the
mid thousands of servers millions of
messages per second ingested continuous
real-time ingest so that the sort of
continuous load of data from a stream
indexing all dimensions by default so
that's that's a cool thing that means as
you're drilling into things you are your
core actual getting faster and faster
because you were using indexes to find
what you're trying to drill into and
identify those rows but even if you're
not doing a drill down even if you're
doing a full scan of the data set we're
still trying to lay things out such that
a full scan can be done in a reasonable
amount of time you quarry through sequel
and we're targeting query latency of sub
second to a few seconds because we are
trying to make these we're trying to
target the ability to build these sort
of interactive analytical applications
so use cases I mentioned these earlier
so I'll skip this a lot of you were
using druid so this is a selection of
people from to repower by page a lot of
the original folks that started using
droid from the beginning so one of the
very first users of druid was Netflix
they're still user today Yahoo's a big
user so it really like a lot of open
source it starts in the internet world
and then kind of meanders out from there
to other places a lot of using it for a
lot of things one thing that one of the
biggest road users Yahoo said they're
very nice is they said some nice things
about us they famously invented Hadoop
and they did a piece in InfoWorld a
couple years back about how they used to
do everything on that do but now they're
starting to migrate some things off of
Hadoop as part of that it sort of you
know explosion of creativity and
applications I was talking about injures
one of the things they're moving things
off onto so the performance is great
some of the tables they have internally
of druid have billions and billions of
events in them and they're being scanned
at under a second so that's you know
that's what we're trying to do and was
actually being achieved at large sites
like Yahoo
I wanted to talk a little bit about the
architecture one thing that's
interesting is that let's see if we go
all the way back to let's see this slide
and sort of the the end state of how you
build a real-time dashboard with us with
a stream processor you see a few things
here you see that you have this key
value store that were using for
aggregates that have been finalized we
have this state in the stream processor
we're using to read current aggregates
we have this real-time dashboard that's
going to be hitting both of them so
that's going to be something generally
that's being mediated at the application
level you have this and you have this
continuous query that's that's pulling
things in to really both of those stores
and this architecture is a lot simpler
this architecture is you know I just
have a load into a database and the
database is doing all that stuff but
internally it looks like this so
internally this this diagram is actually
showing something that's kind of similar
to what you would have set up with a
stream processor to build a real-time
dashboards you has you have files and
streams coming in to the left-hand side
to what we call indexers and druid and
these indexers are responsible for
reading the incoming stream of data
they're responsible for computing
partial aggregates on them if you're
doing if you're doing irrigation at
ingest time so there's there's a mode in
joyed where you agree it in just a
moment aggregate ingest time and just
have the raw data so if you have the raw
data they're indexing the raw data
they're building indexes off of that and
if you are doing aggregation at ingest
time then they're doing the they're
doing that so in general they're going
to be dealing with maybe the most recent
hour of data and then we have these
things called historical servers and
historical are dealing with anything
older than that anything older than
roughly about an hour and this is kind
of you know it kind of feels equivalent
to the two ways of querying data in the
in what we had in the real-time
dashboard example and in fact you
actually do query both so there's a
juried query broker that when a query
comes in it goes to the query broker the
broker just routes it to the appropriate
data servers and it's gonna route it to
both indexers and historical so it'll
get the most currently being indexed
data from the indexer
it'll get historical data from
historical it'll merge it together and
it'll turn it to you and this all
happens in about a second or less so
it's it's under the hood doing a lot of
the same techniques but it's all
packaged up into a single database and
of course one thing that's that's
different about it when they special
about it is that the data format on disk
on the historical z-- so the indexers
have like a relatively inefficient data
format but they're only dealing with the
most recent hour of beta the historical
czar dealing with data going you know
back years potentially
so all the data on the historical x' is
stored in this optimized indexed
columnar form that can be scanned
quickly and then why this works is
computers are fast these days so indexes
are good they help save work and they
help save costs so the indexes are
really there so if you do have a filter
on a query you're able to resolve that
query quicker than you could otherwise
and more cheaply in terms of processor
power like any other horizontally
scalable system you know you can keep
scaling out as long as you want
drew has the ability to do sub-second
queries on almost as much days you can
think of by scaling out but it's you
know scaling that's expensive so we also
try to get really good single machine
performance so indexes help save work in
cost but also don't be afraid to scan
tables it can be done efficiently and in
particular you can get sub-second scans
of even very big tables I want talk a
little bit about integration patterns
so how druid integrates with other
things this is similar to soda guards we
had earlier so if you have a stream hub
and the defense stream coming in
millions events per second enrichment
happening on the stream hub so that
might be happening with a stream
processor data being you tennis lee
loaded into druid i'll call this a
modern data architecture so it's a
stream oriented architecture where you
have this the stream hub in the middle
you have enrichment happening on it you
have things being going and things going
elsewhere outside of that centered
around a stream hub you know I just can
do the same thing with a data Lake so I
talked about streaming this whole time
but how streaming is the future and blah
blah blah blah and I hope I've convinced
you but at the same time data leaks are
a thing there
and it's at least for our community
important to support them so George also
works with data lakes and in that world
you're gonna have file dumps coming in
you know hourly or daily or what have
you
the data Lake is gonna be HDFS or s3
you're still gonna be doing enrichment
but rather than doing in Richmond with a
stream processor you do enrichment with
spark or hive so same kind of concept
but different tools this really kind of
I think to me is an illustration of the
fact that the stream architectures and
the lake architectures are actually
conceptually very very similar and
organized very similarly just you know
streaming versus batch is the main
difference so a slightly less modern
data architecture you know about ten
years less modern centered around a data
Lake instead of a stream hub and finally
you don't have talked with the community
so like I mentioned Apache druid is a
community project I am Jared and so can
you everybody's welcome we have a
community site Jared that Apache org our
old community sites on Georgio we still
have a lot of content there we're
working on moving that content to the
Apache site as part of our journey
through the Apache Incubator on the way
to becoming a top of a project and then
I work at imply the imply distribution
of jury which includes pivot is
available in plaited io / get started
you can contribute on github Aldred
development happens on github github
comm / apache / druid and follow us on
twitter and you can also join the
community the mailing list the dev
mailing list is where a lot of dev
discussions happened user mailing list
for user questions and github for issues
pull requests all comers welcome and and
thank you any questions I'm sorry I came
in a little late and not super familiar
with druid but can you talk a little bit
about like you mentioned horizontal
scalability do you guys have any plans
to decouple storage from compute or is
it already decoupled I guess in that
direction or in that vein yeah that's
that's an interesting question I
appreciate you calling that out I kind
of like slid over that part in the talk
but it's in my mind
compute and storage in the way that
juror does things in the wager
integrates the d-theta world is both
coupled and decoupled and what I mean by
coupled is that the druid data servers
do you have the data they're gonna
process locally in a lot of situations
it's already pre cached in memory and
when it's not pre cached in memory it's
it's kept on local disk one of the
reasons we do that is to be as fast as
we can be I mean people like a pretty
typical performance envelope for a
well-tuned your cluster is that even on
huge data sets the queries are happening
and you know 40 milliseconds to a few
hundred milliseconds and that kind of
perf it's coupling is helpful for that
but decoupling is also useful for data
management you know in the in the I
would say one thing that defines Big
Data architectures is you don't have one
copy of your data you don't have your
data living in just one system you sort
of have a lot of systems used for
different purposes and to that end
Druids ingest model as a pull based
model and it's designed to be able to
pull from s3 pull from HDFS pull from
Kafka so the idea is that it is aware of
systems like that and can stay in sync
with them but it doesn't query directly
out of them so what it does is you tell
Giroud you know I want you to make a
druid table based on this Kafka topic
it's not going to query from Kafka so
it's not going to be like a decoupled in
that sense but it will stay in sync with
Kafka it'll do a continuous load from
Kafka and as you add stuff to Kafka
it'll also add to the Douro table
automatically so that's kind of the idea
and you know what I mean by we try to do
both I have one so you mentioned you
support a high ingestion rate and you're
you don't want us to be afraid of table
scans and those both sound great but
disks are shared resources in this
scenario and there only so many iOS that
you can do per second is there a tension
between those two for example at runtime
heavy heavy duty queries and then maybe
your ingestion rate has to slow down is
there anything like that yeah that's a
really good question so if I go back
well I don't need to go back but there's
sort of people that are writing it's
super high ingest rates so I had those
box up there for indexers and for a
store
you actually for a small or midsize
cluster we suggest for simplicity's sake
running them on the same machines but
for big clusters or clusters that have
heavy heavy right loads we suggest
splitting them up for that reason so you
actually have machines you know in a
hundred node cluster you might have 15
machines dedicated to ingestion and then
85 dedicated to historical quarry
[Music]